hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet what you're about to hear
is a clip from a conversation that i had
with sex and relationships educator and
creator hannah witton and we touched on
the topic of how many sexual partners is
too many and should we care about this
idea of body count when it comes to sex
and relationships and honestly i think
hannah's advice here is really spot on
and i'd love to hear what you guys think
in the comments as well anyway let's
roll the clip on a similar vein what's
your take on
the usefulness of number of sexual
partners yeah i also think that that's
another another one that just like you
shouldn't care
um
i think it's more about like
the attitudes that people have maybe
like i think it's a useful thing to have
conversations with like potential like
romantic and sexual partners about like
their attitudes towards casual sex and
their attitudes towards like
why they've slept with that many people
or why they've not slept with that many
people
rather than it being about like
the number itself having holding any
information like
what does that as you would say data
point tell you like what like i think
actually being able to drill down to
with somebody about like how were those
experiences like did you have a good
time like
wha what was your motivation for not
having sex outside a relationship what
was your motivation for like having lots
of sex outside like like casual sex and
stuff i think that will tell you a lot
more about a person than like the hard
number itself um okay yeah
for the record i'm with you on this one
um but i've spoken to a few a few of my
guy friends and
tried to
argue that point of view of like a
number of sexual partners shouldn't
matter come on guys you know it's a 21st
century let's let's move on et cetera et
cetera to which our response i've often
heard is
look there is a difference between
someone who's had three sexual partners
and someone who's had 300 sexual
partners what difference do they see
what's the difference that they're
thinking about is it like a difference
in like
a person's attitudes towards sex i
suspect that's probably what they're
getting at well so that's maybe what
they should be focusing on also what
standards do they hold themselves to
like are they also the kind of person
who would maybe only be having three
sexual
partners total right
because there can be a lot of like
judgment and double standards yeah there
as well so like for somebody who's slept
with three people versus someone who
slept with 300 to these friends
like what information is that telling
you
about them like what kind of girl is
that versus what kind of girl is that
and what is it about one over the other
that you prefer rather than like so
ignore the number like actually drill
down of like what assumptions are you
making about that person's character
what assumptions are you making about
that kind of person's
um values or lifestyle
or sti status like we could be
and so actually like
there's probably a lot of assumptions
that they're holding about these two
like fictional characters in their head
um
and and then also asking themselves do
you hold yourself to the same standards
like and how would you feel if somebody
else judged you a certain way based on
the
number of people that you'd slept with
yeah yeah and then just being like you
know genoa is absolutely fine i think if
for you
sex is something that you only want to
share with a certain kind of person so
maybe your your number is lower and
maybe the people that you want to have
sex with have us have similar values to
you it just so happens then
that your
both of your numbers are low
but it's actually the values that you're
holding in the beliefs that you're
holding that are the things that make
you compatible rather than like the fact
that you've both only slept with three
people
you could also have somebody who like
has lived a whole life yeah had a lot of
casual sex and then like come out of
that and been like actually like i've
now discovered that this is what i want
and actually i want the
next time that i sleep with someone for
it to be like somebody that i'm in a
loving relationship with so maybe they
would actually still be compatible with
that person but their number's way
higher yeah that's really good yeah i
think that's that that thing of like the
the the number is that it's not about
the number it's about the values that
you think that you're kind of assuming
that that number kind of correlates yeah
and we should talk about the values so
the next time one of your friends goes
like oh well i wouldn't i wouldn't want
to date someone who slept with 300
people just be like tell me about that
person yeah this person this imaginary
person in your mind who slept with 300
people tell me about them and what is it
what are the things about them that it
that you think makes them undateable for
you hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day